nous sommes ici place de l'ancienne
douane au coeur de colmar
tout à côté des canaux de la petite
venise et de la langue
l'eau a de tout temps été un élément
déterminant et structurant de ce
territoire
lille est la véritable colonne
vertébrale de notre canton colmar 2 qui
s'étend sous la cité de bartholdi et sur
le ride mais aussi le rhin en effet
notre territoire a la chance d'être au
coeur de l'une des régions
transfrontalières les plus dynamiques
d'europe aux portes de l'allemagne et à
proximité de la suisse
cette dynamique rhénane c'est celle pour
laquelle nous nous engageons pour créer
de l'emploi et des opportunités pour nos
jeunes c'est pour aller encore plus loin
que nous portons la reconstruction de la
liaison ferroviaire colmar freiburg qui
permettra demain de vivre dans un bassin
de vie franco-allemand de quatre cent
mille habitants
notre canton est un territoire aux
visages multiples à l'image d'autres
départements du rhin en effet s'il a
pris le nom de son chef lieu qui à
colmar
il n'en est pas mois à dominante rurale
et regroupe entre autres tous les
villages de la partie méridionale du
grand ried des villages qui affiche tous
pas dynamisme démographique très
important et qui sont évidemment orienté
vers le monde à l'école setao le ciré à
riquewihr que par exemple sont cultivés
les aminches la choucroute d'alsace le
canton est également riche en
initiatives commerciales artisanales et
industrielles des zones commerciales
celle de colmar houssen en particulier
qui propose aux consommateurs les
enseignes les plus variés et les plus
diverses
nous avons évidemment de nombreuses
entreprises dynamiques innovantes riche
de savoir-faire notamment l'entreprise
de construction g à deux sacres en
plaine qui a à son actif deux
remarquables réalisations le campus
thales à bordeaux la plate forme de
chirurgie ambulatoire la pitié
salpêtrière à paris
aujourd'hui la nouvelle plateforme e
commerce d'amazon
à brétigny sur orge notre canton offre
l'image du mariage parfait entre la
ville et la campagne
c'est un territoire où il fait bon vivre
les milieux naturels du ried et les
vastes forêts périurbaines offre à tous
des espaces de loisirs de grande qualité
mais nous avons aussi la chance de
représenter un territoire qui abrite un
patrimoine culturel et architectural
exceptionnel
le centre historique de colmar est riche
de prestigieux témoignages
architecturaux le musée unterlinden chez
l'un des musées de beaux-arts des plus
visités de france
autant d'atouts qui font que colmar
attire chaque année 3 5 millions de
visiteurs soit plus du tiers des
touristes qui séjournent en alsace mais
la véritable richesse de ce territoire
se sont évidemment ses hommes le canton
est riche d'un formidable tissu
associatif par exemple à horbourg-wihr
vous avez le club de canoë-kayak apache
qui a donné à notre région où de
nombreux champions de france
les champions d'europe et même des
champions du monde vous avez aussi
rendre le times le club de course à pied
les faveurs anr qui sont à l'initiative
de belles manifestations tout à la fois
sportive et humaine
et puis à colmar vous avez l'association
espoir qui est un modèle national en
matière de réinsertion sociale